Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel has
been filming Captain America 4 and thanks to
some new crew members posting pictures that they
definitely weren't supposed to be posting it looks
like Tom Hall and Spider-Man is going to be in
the movie along with some Daredevil born-again
connections so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos I'll be doing episode videos
for Daredevil born again when it starts which is
also going to be around the same time Captain
America 4 Brave New World new title is going
to start so it makes sense that they want some
of what's going on during Daredevil born again
to connect with the movies that are coming out
then the funny thing about that though is that
Daredevil Born Again season 1 is going to be
18 episodes they'll get multiple Seasons but
that means that season one with a break in the
middle that we all expect there'll be like nine
episodes then a break then the rest of the Nine
episodes will overlap with most of the Marvel
movies coming out in 2024 so it makes sense
that they wanted to cross over with a bunch of
movies there's a lot of stuff happening during
Daredevil born again that will also culminate
with this whole dark rain Aaron Marvel Phase 5
during Captain America 4. but starting with a
big step first Tom Hall and Spider-Man coming
back before the events of Spider-Man 4 people
were reporting that a stunt double working on
Captain America 4 posted this picture featuring
work that they were doing on current Marvel
series and movies just at first glance though
it has a couple titles that they're working on
that don't seem totally related without thinking
too much about it like it has Captain America 4
Brave New World on it but it also features akatha
coven of Chaos in another season 2 of a show with
a working title that's cut off in frame like Zoom
enhancer it seems like it says big door prize
season two there are only a couple of Series
right now that Marvel's doing that have gotten
season twos like Loki season 2 what if season
2 Spider-Man freshman year season 2 is supposed
to be called Spider-Man sophomore year but that's
animated and Vincent de nofrio did confirm that
they're doing Daredevil Born Again season 2 but
they haven't started filming that yet because
they're still in the middle of filming season
one so I think the idea is that the schedule
in this picture is meant to be for stuff that
Marvel has already worked on or is in the middle
of working on right now and because I do not not
believe that Tom Holland Spider-Man is actually
in Agatha the coven of chaos like that would be
crazy like what's he gonna be doing in Agatha the
Covenant of chaos I actually did bite a kid once
if the people reporting on this picture are saying
that it confirms that Spider-Man is in Captain
America four and it was his stunt double posting
this picture then his stunt double for Spider-Man
stuff might also just be working on other stuff
other movies and other TV shows as different
characters because Marvel's stunt doubles and the
crew members do a lot of that like they work on
multiple projects as different characters but
if this picture is to be believed and it means
that Tom Hall and Spider-Man is in Captain
America for I don't know how big of a scene
he would have if it's meant to be like Spider-Man
during Captain America's Civil War where he was a
brief but important part of the plot or its much
quicker scene Tom Holland also just said that he's
taking a break from acting for the rest of this
year just because the crowded room his last big
series took such a toll on him and he knows he's
going to be doing Spider-Man 4 eventually soon too
I'm gonna have to uh plead the fifth there because
I'm not prepared to start talking about the future
of Spider-Man as everyone knows I love him he
changed my life I love the character should we
find a way to tell his story and do justice to
him we will do so but that said if I just play
Spider-Man for the rest of my life I'd be still
the luckiest kid alive uh so there's there's no
complaints from me here the other reason for
him to take a break is because he knew he'd
be doing something small for Captain America
four to if that is to be believed he did talk
recently about doing more Marvel projects but he
was mostly talking about Spider-Man 4 and doing
work with live action Miles Morales which they
just announced that they're making a movie for
like they are doing a live-action Miles Morales
movie but there's also rumors about him being
in Spider-Man 4 as well that MCU version of Miles
Morales the other big thing that just happened too
is Captain America 4 was recently filming scenes
in New York City where Spider-Man and Daredevil
are right now because it's taking place around
the same time in a regular Daredevil location
like they were filming Captain America four
scenes at a daredevil location which I think
makes a little more sense if we're talking about
crossing over with the events of Daredevil Born
Again In Spider-Man being around the same area
the scenes themselves were at Canal Street which
were featured heavily during Daredevil Netflix
and if you start thinking about it why would
Captain America 4 need to go to New York City if
all the biggest characters that we know about at
the moment in the movie are located mostly around
the Washington DC area or internationally the main
plot of the movie is Thunderbolt Ross and Val
sending the serpent Society to get adamantium on
team its body which is in the Indian Ocean on the
other side of the planet and to boot Thunderbolt
Ross supposed to become Red Hulk he's also
supposed to become the president of the United
States that's Washington DC area Val is also
director of the CIA right now that's much closer
to the Washington DC area pretty much all those
Falcon and Winter Soldier scenes that we saw with
all those characters that are returning during the
movie even Sharon Carter going on trial was in the
Washington DC area so it's not like the leader
for example who we know is coming back from the
Incredible Hulk in the movie to turn Thunderbolt
Ross into Red Hulk is going to be doing so in a
New York City basement on Canal Street or anything
like that but because the events of the movie will
be taking place around the same time Daredevil
Born Again episodes are starting next year it
makes sense that they would want to touch on
what's happening in New York City in general
with Kingpin Daredevil the Spider-Man character
because you think about it Kingpin is called the
Kingpin of crime it would be interesting to see
what connections he has with Sharon Carter her
power broker operation in madrapore and also with
Val's character if this is sort of a Marvel Phase
5 dark rain ERA with the villains seizing power
doing whatever they want turning America into
something that's more akin to like a police state
to make another defender's pun ruling America in
in kingpin's case New York City with an iron fist
it feels like if they don't start out Daredevil
born again with Kingpin knowing Val for instance
or Sharon Carter he will eventually know them just
because they have access to so much technology
Black Market Tech and it sounds like Val would
be willing to let him do pretty much whatever
he wants to do think about the resources she has
access to as director of the CIA with someone
like Thunderbolt Ross being president of the
United States willing to sign off on anything that
she wants to do so while the craziness of Marvel
Phase 5 is going to culminate in Captain America
4 around the same time that Daredevil Born Again
episodes are starting so it makes sense that
that would all cross over and connect with each
other let me know in the comments though if
Captain America 4 is filming in New York City
right now what do you think that they're doing
there in the movie Charlie Cox was also talking
about working with Tom Holland doing Spider-Man
stuff and coming back in Spider-Man 4 so it does
sound like there's a good chance that Spider-Man 4
will feature the daredevil characters coming back
and he was he was so generous and kind and you
know made me feel very welcome you know he was
in the middle of a long shoot and I'm sure he
was exhausted and I know what that's like and
I was in in a scene with him for one day um
so it was a huge honor and we we had a great
time together and you know it would be great to
share the stream with him again at some point
you'll sit here yeah he talked about that
and we talked about the character and uh you
know he's awesome and they're all up it was
great I gotta get you one day spread around
the other cool thing is that Kevin feige did
say that what's happening during Daredevil
born again will figure heavily into the plot
of Spider-Man 4 even if all the daredevil
characters don't come back in Spider-Man 4
just some of them like the important ones
you have to remember there's going to be 18
episodes of Daredevil Born Again season one
so that's like a lot of room for characters
to show up like Punisher for example is going
to be a huge character during season one side
Note 2 it was also just reported that Punisher
is going to get his own brand new series on
Disney plus and now Disney plus can develop
TV MA or like rated R material on Disney plus
so they can do a rated R level Punisher still
ah it feels great try to do this as fast as you
humanly possibly can okay don't worry about Satan
four seconds four seconds the fastest time of
all goodness gracious there are a couple upcoming
rated R Marvel movies like Deadpool 3's rated R
the blade movie supposed to be rated R so they
can't actually do that but if we're talking about
Spider-Man those are the big characters showing
up in Captain America four think about it this
way the only reason they went to New York City
in Captain America Civil War was when Iron Man
was picking up Spider-Man and even though he and
Falcon were together during the final battle in
Avengers end game in Iron Man's funeral the last
real major scene they actually share together like
speaking to each other was when they fought each
other in Captain America Civil War the other
thing that's supposed to happen during Captain
America 4 is they're supposed to set up the idea
of what the new Avengers team is going to look
like Spider-Man might have something to do with
that because he will be in Avengers 5 King Dynasty
on that new Avengers team and if he does show up
in Captain America 4 it'll be interesting to see
what the true extent of Doctor Strange's spell is
like how close to the writers of the movie stick
to what the rules of the spell are technically
everyone still still supposed to remember that
Spider-Man the character exists everything he did
with the Avengers they just don't remember the
Spider-Man is also Peter Parker everything else
they remember so Falcon and Winter Soldier for
example would remember that Spider-Man put them
on their asses they'll be filming the movie for
a while and they'll also be filming Daredevil
born again for most of this year so I'll do
videos for everything like Daredevil Spider-Man 4
Captain America 4 as we get more footage the other
big thing that's starting really soon or secret
Invasion episodes I'll be doing weekly episode
videos for that just like all the other Marvel
Disney plus Series be sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that they just
released the entire episode 1 opening scene
click here to watch that and click here for my
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse teaser video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!